ludmila s'en va-t-en guerre documentaire
signé ludmilla zee avec nicolas bourgoin
15 nécessaires sur le cancer du sein
chez les jeunes femmes à l'occasion
d'octobre rose avec nous pour en parler
aujourd'hui l'umih l'asie bienvenue vous
êtes donc la réalisatrice de ce
documentaire et vous êtes journaliste
indépendante avec nos également
dominique vais rien bienvenue vous êtes
sénatrice centriste de l'yonne vice
présidente de la délégation aux droits
des femmes et du groupe d'études cancer
au sénat dr florence coup-ci bienvenue à
vous elle gynécologue oncologue à
l'institut curie et natacha espié
bienvenue vous êtes psychologue et
président de l'association europa donna
france merci à tous d'être avec nous le
2000 a d'abord comment allez vous et
comment vous une jeune femme que l'on
voit dans le documentaire et becousse et
merci déjà de me recevoir ici
aujourd'hui mais je vais très bien j'ai
terminé mes traitements lourds il ya
environ un an et demi et maintenant je
suis sous traitement hormonal donc je
prends l'hormonothérapie et pendant
quatre ans encore c'est un petit
médicament que je prends tous les soirs
et ç'a permis d' éviter une récidive
et les personnes qui ont témoigné dans
le film donc maiva à christelle et guen
vont très bien aussi les ont tous
terminé leur traitement et et tout se
passe bien pour elle j'ai vu d'ailleurs
christ est le week-end dernier à
bordeaux on a fait un petit événement
pour la section jeunes et rose et ils
vont tous très bien nous voilà ravis et
rassurer fleuron ce coup ci c'est vrai
que ce sont des cancers qui sont très
rares ces cancers chez les - de quoi 35
40 ans alors finalement c'est des
cancers qu'ont dit rare parce que ça
c'est à peu près 5% des cancers du sein
en france mais finalement c'est 3000 cas
par an de femmes jeunes de moins de 40
au qui auront un cancer dont finalement
c'est un chiffre qui n'est pas du tout
négligeable donc pas si rare que ça et
donc ça nécessite vraiment qu'on s'en
occupe et quelle est la tendance est ce
qu'ils augmentent sont alors en fait
l'incidence du cancer en france
augmentent et ce dans toutes les
tranches d'âge donc pas plus chez les
jeunes que chez les moins jeunes comme
l'incidence augmente de manière
parallèle quelle que soit la tranche
d'âge ce sont des cancers plus agressif
aussi parce que du fait de l'âge du fait
du jeune âge justement alors globalement
là il ya des petites différences qu'on
retrouve dans le cancer du sein de la
femme jeune c'est le cancer du sein
ressemble quand même quel que soit l'âge
mais finalement il ya une représentation
d'une forme qui édite un petit peu
agressif qui est la forme triple
négative et c'est vrai qu'elle est sur
représentée chez la femme jeune c'est à
peu près 10% des cancers du sein en
général mais plutôt 15 à 17% chez la
femme jeune c'est avec cette forme est
un peu plus agressive est sur
représentée chez les femmes plus jeunes
natacha espié c'est vrai que ce qu'on
remarque dans le documentaire et ce qui
frappe chez toutes ces jeunes femmes
c'est qu'elle s'attende pas une seconde
d'avoir un cancer du sein à leur âge il
ya un choc terrible parce que quand on
est jeune on peut pas imaginer qu'on
avoir un cancer tout à fait vous avez
raison quand on est jeune on vit dans
une sorte d'un vulgaire habilité et
c'est pas du tout un âge où on peut se
projeter dans la maladie et c'est ça qui
rend cet événement de vie aussi
difficile à supporter et puis cet
isolement parce que comme le disait
florence finalement il n'y a pas
énormément de cas et ces jeunes femmes
se retrouvent dans un isolement même
dans les services même au sein des
services et ça je pense que c'est assez
terrible pour elle dominique vais rien
qu'est ce qui vous a inspiré ce
documentaire ce cas de l'onu là est le
cas de toutes ces jeunes femmes que l'on
découvre alors j'ai trouvé très
intéressant enfin très intéressant la
façon dont vous vous battez est en fait
voilà c'est une maladie et donc on doit
pouvoir en guérir et ça c'est
intéressant aussi d'avoir cette vision
du cancer
après je j'étais désespérée quand j'ai
entendu que certaines parce que souvent
on va pas se faire dépister mais celle
qui a voulu y aller et dont le médecin
ne voulaient pas croire que ça pouvait
être un cancer donc se dire que soi même
déjà on n'y croit pas on n'y va pas mais
qu'en plus quand on pense que peut-être
c'est ça et qu'on va voir un médecin
qu'on n'ait pas entendu c'est assez
terrible et puis ensuite la double peine
qui est après c'est comment on continue
sa vie une fois qu'on est n'a été malade
jeune et qu'on a du mal à reconstruire
parce que les assurances ne suivent pas
parce que on reste longtemps une
personne à risque c'est intéressant
parce que vous avez soulevé tout un tas
de questions qu'on va se pose
effectivement dans mon coeur de ce débat
peut-être un mot d'abord pour vous
florence coup ci on en guérit de du
cancer du sein est plus ou moins
lorsqu'on les jeunes oui on en guérit
finalement du cancer du sein
la survie à 5 ans est de +2 88% donc
c'est un cancer qu'on dit nous de bons
pronostics donc oui c'est un concert
dont on guérit et justement cette après
cancer est d'autant plus important parce
qu'il faut retourner dans la vie pour la
majorité de nos patientes et donc il
faut s'attacher justement à ce que cette
vie soit la meilleure possible et on va
voir comment on va voir si la société
nous yens ou pas d'abord le problème
c'est que parce que ces cancers sont
rares on a aussi tendance à les oublier
un peu c'est aussi ce que vous dites
dans votre film ludmilla on va revoir ce
moment que vous avez passé avec des
représentantes de la ligue contre le
cancer et on en parle juste après
qu'est ce que la ligue fait en matière
de prévention action prévention pour
sensibiliser les jeunes au cancer du
sein
quand on fait des
de la communication si on met des photos
d'une très jolie jeune femme avec une
belle poitrine et c'est qu'à 30 ans ça
correspond pas c'est pas cohérent avec
le message
général qui doit être portée c'est un
drôle d'aveu qu'elle nous fait là vous
avez été surprise même part ça répond
oui complètement complètement c'est vrai
que je veux pas leur casser voilà du
sucre dando parce que la liga était
vraiment super pendant ma période de
soins j'y suis beaucoup allé pendant mes
traitements et on va vraiment très bien
prise en charge donc pour ça ils sont
vraiment top mais c'est vrai que j'ai
été surprise de voir qu'en fait en terme
de communication pour les jeunes et
avait pas grand chose lorsque j'y allais
je réalise sur le joaillier sur les
prospectus des photos de femmes plus
âgées
très voilà donc assez surprise c'est
pour ça que je suis allé les voir pour
leur poser la question et leur réponse
m'a un peu étonné oui parce que c'est
vrai que on se dit que c'est vrai on
reste une minorité il me semble 3% à
être des fans au moins 35 ans est touché
par un cancer du sein mais quand même il
y en a il y en a quand même beaucoup et
c'est important d'en parler donc oui
surprise je pense ça vous interpellez
dominique vais rien on sacrifie une
minorité pour la majorité
ça m'a interpellé je pense
qu'effectivement il faut prendre
conscience qu'on peut être malade à tout
âge de toute façon est plutôt on en
prend conscience et plus on pourra faire
de la prévention donc et peut-être que
ça commence par l'école pour apprendre à
connaître son corps à savoir et et
veiller à ce que tout le monde sache que
oui malheureusement on peut être malade
même quand on est jeune c'est à dire dès
l'école est là dès l'école pour pouvoir
aussi parce que souvent comment on se
croit invulnérable quand on est jeune on
n'imagine pas et donc on n'a pas
forcément non plus les gestes pour
savoir tiens j'ai une boule là est ce
que c'est normal ou non se doit être
rien
si dès le plus jeune âge on sait qu' il
faut apprendre à connaître son corps et
à avoir les alertes quand il ya quelque
chose qui dysfonctionne et du coup à ce
moment-là savoir à des trouver la
réponse chez un médecin peut-être qu'on
pourra soigner plus et c'est une forme
de prévention
dès le plus jeune âge elle est
compliquée cette question de prévention
d'attaché espèces qu'on n'a pas non plus
envie d'être anxiogène d'angoissé des
jeunes femmes qui ont aussi envie d'être
associant t elle on loin oui tout à fait
alors il ya plusieurs choses la réponse
de la dame de la ligue effectivement moi
je veux pas du tout
enfoncez comme vous l'avez dit très bien
tout à l'heure mais simplement je pense
que ça touche aux représentations
inconsciente comme pour les médecins au
fond on n'a pas envie de se dire qu'une
femme jeunes peuvent être touchées par
le cancer donc du coup on va mettre ça
très à distance je pense que c'est vrai
aussi pour les jeunes femmes qui sont
enceintes et auquel on retrouve à un
cancer du sein où ça peut être très
compliquée et la question de la
prévention oui c'est compliqué je
partage tout à fait votre avis je pense
que ce serait très important d'expliquer
aux enfants leur corps ça touche tout un
tas de dimensions y compris la
protection des enfants voilà et de
comprendre et surtout je pense que c'est
très important d'écouter les femmes
quand une jeune femme vient dire mon
sein est pas normal je sens quelque
chose je pense que d'abord on écoute je
le pense les patientes et je pense que
florent sera d'accord avec moi c'est la
première des choses à mon avis et après
sur la question de la prévention ça je
pense que c'est compliqué on
tue répondre est beaucoup mieux que moi
mais on y met plein de choses là-dedans
un mois je suis simplement très attentif
à ne pas culpabiliser les femmes c'est à
dire de quoi d'être passé à côté de
quelque chose mais qu'après vous savez
on dit alors les bonnes pratiques c'est
toujours important pour la santé mais il
faut être extrêmement attentive à après
pas leur dire ah bah oui tu stresses est
trop tu mangeais mal et il ya une sorte
de culpabilisation qui peut s'opérer
auprès des femmes et je pense qu'il faut
être aussi attentive donc effectivement
vous avez raison le sentier est un peu
étroit entre les deux et puis il ya une
forme de d'irrégularités selon les
médecins dr florence qosi qui vous
apprennent ou non à vous auto palper
gérer des gestes à apprendre technique
quand même oui alors sur ce qui sur ce
qui est de la prévention en fait près la
prévention c'est là quand on parle de
l'auto palpation c'est le dépistage
injuste aussi pour revenir sur le
dépistage pensait bien un mot important
c'est le dépistage il existe de 50 à 74
ans et une mammographie tous les deux
ans où les femmes sont invitées à y
aller ça fonctionne puisque ça on grâce
à ça on améliore la survie de nos
patients donc c'est très bien dépistage
mais il ya à peine 50% des femmes
françaises qui vont au dépistage donc ça
c'est une première chose pour les femmes
entre 50 et 74 ans et puis après quand
même pour les femmes plus jeunes y'a pas
rien il ya la consultation aller voir
son gynécologue annuel ça c'est vraiment
une recommandation à partir de 25 ans
même avant on va voir son gynécologue de
manière annuelle et le gynécologue nous
palper les seins ça c'est important et
puis il ya aussi en effet apprendre à
connaître ses seins alors on pas d'auto
palpation c'est vrai que l'auto
palpation n'a pas montré non plus qu on
améliorait la survie des patientes à
l'encontre d'accords l'auto palpation
elle a montré que connaître ses seins on
est beaucoup plus proactif à avoir à s'y
lie à une anomalie aller voir son
gynécologue son médecin pour après
pouvoir faire des analyses
complémentaires des biopsies voilà donc
apprendre à se connaître et apprendre à
connaître ses seins ça me parait majeur
et et je ne vais pas mettre des
gynécologues ou dans les écoles
peut-être non mais une fois par an faire
passer un gynécologue auprès de jeunes
filles pour leur expliquer que faut
qu'elles soient vigilantes qu'elle
regarde dans les lycées je ne sais pas
c'est bien sûr c'est une très bonne idée
et puis aussi
je pense qu'il faut aussi promouvoir le
fait que oui il faut aller voir son
gynécologue une fois par an même quand
on est jeune même à 25 ans il faut y
aller c'est une fois par an et le
gynécologue c'est le saint c'est aussi
vous savez le dépistage du cancer du col
de l'utérus et c'est énormément de
choses donc je pense qu'aussi il faut
promouvoir à d'aller voir son
gynécologue ou la personne qui va suivre
nous suivre au niveau gynécologique
c'est je pense très important puis je
vous rappeler leur rapport qui vient de
sortir de la délégation aux droits des
femmes fait montre que 17 départements
n'ont pas de gynécologues donc déjà ils
ne sont pas là pour soigner pour
accompagner gynécologues médicaux pas
gynecology médicaux oui tout à fait
c'est à dire qu'on peut accoucher mais
on n'est pas suivi donc effectivement on
sera pas dépister non plus
alors on a des sages femmes heureusement
alors peut-être qu'il faut déléguer la
plutôt des sages femmes mais sur le 50 %
qui ne va pas se faire dépister on a
aussi en secteur rural le fait que si on
n'a pas une demi journée devant soi on
va pas aller faire une mammographie
parce que c'est loin est ce qu'il faut
faire 50 km à l'est 50 km tour plus le
temps d'attentes plus le temps de la
mammographie est donc comme on est en
bonne santé ben on va pas se faire
dépister éventuellement on ira chez un
spécialiste si on est malade mais on va
pas y aller pour quelque chose d'autant
que là aussi on l'a vu en milieu rural
les femmes sont celles qui prennent en
charge le plus les transports des
enfants et c'est
sans compter que c'est là aussi qu'il ya
le plus de femmes qui ne conduisent pas
donc elles sont automatiquement elles se
sacrifie par rapport à ça et donc
n'iront pas se faire dépister parce que
c'est du temps et je rebondis aussi sur
l'annexé de remarques de tout à l'heure
dominique derrien et parce que moi aussi
ça m'a frappé dans votre documentaire
l'unmis l'asie c'est le manque de
formation peut-être des médecins c'est à
dire qu'on voit cette jeune femme qui
elle même est médecin qui pleure dans
les bras de sa soeur parce qu'elle n'a
même pas su elle n'a pas envisagé une
seconde que sa soeur à son âge puissent
avoir un cancer du sein et l'autre qui
explique qu'elle se fait par don du mot
anglais aux urgences elles ont gorge les
urgences parce que
la place de quelqu'un d'autre oui c'est
vrai que c'est choquant ça m'a vraiment
marqué lorsque j'ai rencontré ces jeunes
femmes qui ont donné ces témoignages moi
personnellement j'ai eu beaucoup de
chance parce que mon cancer a été pris
en charge très vite très tôt ces mêmes
gynécologue qui insistait pour que je
fasse une échographie moi je pourrais je
ne prenais pas vraiment les choses au
sérieux au début mai mais il pour
beaucoup de femmes ça pas été le cas et
c'est vrai qu'on a un peu surpris on se
dit mais les médecins dans l'impression
parfois qui voilà qui ne sont pas
forcément
c'est ça mon papa peut-être aussi parce
que les chiffres leur donnent raison
oui mais alors la problématique la vraie
problématique c'est que le cancer du
sein même s'il est rare il existe et
donc avant de faire un diagnostic
par ses mains et ben on va jusqu'au bout
des choses et on va faire un vrai
diagnostic comme disait avec une éco une
mammo une biopsie et c'est vrai que on
voit chez particulièrement chez les
femmes jeunes ce qu'on appelle l'errance
un petit peu diagnostic de la femme
jeune qui a palpé une lésion puis
finalement elle a été vue par un
professionnel de santé un premier qui
est dit mais non ça n'existe pas en
effet chez la femme jeune c'est un
adénovirus c'est exactement ce qui est
dit dans votre documentaire donc une
lésion bénigne de la femme bien sûr ça
sera le plus souvent heureusement une
lésion bénigne mais dans certains cas ce
n'est pas et donc il faut aller vraiment
jusqu'au bout du diagnostic et on va
jusqu'au bout du diagnostic avec une
échographie complémentaire avec une
biopsie et on pose un vrai diagnostic
qui sera rarement un cancer du sein mais
au moins on sera allé jusqu'au bout
natacha est ce qu'il ya un problème
quand même avec ses médecins qui
ce pouvoir ne veulent pas voir ne
veulent pas voir oui c'est toujours très
compliqué moi je pense qu'il ya un
problème d'information c'est à dire il
faut aussi informer les médecins à dire
exactement ce que j'ai dit et je pense
qu'il y a quelque chose à faire il faut
informer les femmes et il faut informer
les médecins et se souvenir
effectivement que c'est inconcevable
pour e.on
c'est difficilement concevable on va le
dire autrement la clé alors elles vont
moins de 30 35 ans elles ont donc aussi
les codes et les modes d'expression de
femmes de l'orage ça passe donc par les
réseaux sociaux et on est assez frappé
là aussi de voir que certaines d'entre
elles ce film et publie des vidéos
d'elle même lorsqu'elle ne sont pas dans
leur meilleur état regarder quand j'ai
réçu que j'étais malade j'ai eu l'idée
de me créer une page instagram qui
serait un peu comme comme mon exutoire
bon journal intime public
ça m'a permis d'échanger avec beaucoup
de personnes sur des ressentis sur des
vécus sur des champions ou des conseils
mais ces défis avec qui j'échange et que
je comprends et qu'ils me comprennent
les demies l'asie là on est vraiment
dans l'action du rapport à l'image c'est
fou cette importance capitale les
réseaux sociaux notamment pour les
jeunes femmes quand vous mais
complètement et et gwen l'expriment très
bien dans le documentaire c'est vrai
qu'en fait on a l'impression de tomber
sur une communauté de jeunes femmes qui
nous comprennent pas ce qu'elles ont
vécu la même chose travel réseau les
réseaux sociaux si on retrouve beaucoup
de soutiens parce que il ya des
personnes qui nous suivent qu'ils vont
aimer nos vidéos qui vont partager il ya
un échange aussi d'expérience et c'est
quand on est touché par la maladie
jeunes même moins jeunes je pense qu'on
peut se sentir seuls et sur les réseaux
sociaux on retrouve plein de monde avec
qui on peut échanger parler est ce que
c'est parce qu'il ya eu une défaillance
peut-être des proches qui ne savent pas
à réagir qui réagissent mal qui n'ont
pas ou c'est pas de leur foi alors je
vais pas dire ça parce que les proches
france ont un rôle très important et
pour ma part enfin j'étais hyper bien
entouré et
je pense pas que ce soit ça mais c'est
plus le fait que sur la notion peut
trouver des jeunes femmes qui ont vécu
la même chose alors nos proches peuvent
être là et nous donnait beaucoup d'amour
et beaucoup de soutien mais ils ne
comprennent pas complètement ce qu'on a
vécu est donc les réseaux sociaux ça
fait du bien aussi par rapport à ça et
même pouvoir échanger avec des femmes
aussi qu'ils ont vécu la maladie mais
qui ont un stade qui en sont à un stade
différent et même qui en sont sortis
dont on peut leur poser des questions
moi j'avais beaucoup de questions par
rapport à la repousse des cheveux par
rapport à voilà au fait de pouvoir
tomber enceinte après avoir eu des
traitements de chimiothérapie
toutes ces questions là j'ai pu les
poser sur les réseaux sociaux à des
femmes qui a été passée par là et ça m'a
voilà ça m'a vraiment donné une bouffée
d'oxygène et je me suis dit mais whaou
en fait c'est hyper positif il ya des
femmes qui s'en sortent il ya des femmes
qui reprennent une vie complètement
normale après et quand on en traitement
ça fait beaucoup de bien natacha espère
vivre les réseaux sociaux zynga
de le dire mais je pense que vous avez
tout à fait raison là il ya une sorte de
sororité qui ceux qui s'installent alors
les proches bien sûr peuvent être
l'homme et les proches y sont aussi pris
dans leur propre souffrance et qui est
la leur même s'il accompagne très bien
et c'est important de pouvoir échanger
pas ce qu'on va dire à la patiente je
comprends ce que tu ressens non je peut
l'accueillir mais je pourrais jamais
totalement le comprendre parce que je
suis pas à sa place donc je pense que de
pouvoir échanger avec des femmes qui ont
exactement la même expérience ou qui
sont un peu plus en amont ou en aval ça
peut faire beaucoup de bien il a fait
une bonne bouffée d'oxygène dominique
veilleuse que c'est pas aussi parce
qu'il ya peut-être un manque de suivi
psychologique et qu'on devrait
systématiser le suivi psychologique de
ces jeunes femmes pour que peut-être
elle n'est pas forcément besoin de se
retrouver entre elles ou non pas du tout
je suis pas sûr que ce soit le besoin de
suivi psychologique mais plutôt le
besoin d'avoir des repères parce que
quand on a un cancer c'est la première
fois que ça nous arrive avec un peu de
chance il y en a pas eu dans notre
entourage donc on ne sait pas et c'est
vrai qu'on ne sait pas quel est l'avenir
comment ça va fonctionner je parlais
tout à l'heure au maquillage d'un livre
qui s'appelle la guerre des tétons et
qui raconte justement c'est une jeune
femme qui a eu un cancer et qui raconte
réellement toutes les étapes qu'elle a
vécu et objectivement en fait pour
l'avoir vécu également quand on m'a
offert ce livre la personne qui l'a
offert qui me l'a offert n'avait pas
spécialement trouve drôle et moi je ris
à chaque page parce qu'en fait c'étaient
des choses qu'on vivait et mais que moi
je vivais mais que ma nièce mon mari ne
pouvait pas comprendre parce que ce
n'était pas dans cette situation et
parfois ça fait aussi du bien d'en rire
et de se rendre compte que d'autres s'en
sont sortis donc puisque d'autres s'en
sont sortis a pas de raison qu'on le
fasse pas et que voilà sané c'est une
facette une étape dans la vie c'est
peut-être pas une étape qu'on a choisi
mais c'est une étape qu'on peut tout à
fait passé et voilà des livres ça peut
être des réseaux sociaux moi j'étais
plutôt tournés sur des livres que sur
les réseaux sociaux mais mais
effectivement le témoignage de quelqu'un
est de savoir qu'on n'est pas seuls et
que ça peut bien se passer est ce que
ces mêmes à la guérison selon ce coup-ci
d'être bien accompagné j'imagine que
c'est très difficile à chiffrer mais est
ce que vous voyez un mieux chez ces
patientes qui sont plus connectés ou qui
lisent plus alors je sais pas si ça aide
à la guérison moi ce que je vois c'est
que les réseaux sociaux sont quand même
peuvent être d'une grande aide alors il
ya deux choses ya ce que vous avez
remarqué ça ça crée des liens entre les
femmes et ça je pense que c'est très
important il ya un soutien il ya un
échange d'expériences qui est majeure
enfin c'est ce que me disent mais mes
patientes ça crée aussi une diffusion de
l'information scientifique mes patientes
ont accès très facilement et très
rapidement aux informations de qualité
est donc nommé patients en consultation
connaissent leur maladie connaissent les
traitements et pas des risques aux
informations alors rien il est au fort
de fausses informations après il faut
savoir suivre aussi voilà il ya l'inca
qui qu'1 l'institut du cancer qui
donnent des informations complètement
fiable voilà on peut suivre l'institut
curie aussi via une page et je pense que
l'information sur les traitements aussi
sur le cancer lui même fait que les
patientes sont informés connaissent
mieux et je pense qu'il ya eu il ya
moins d'appréhension sur / en
particulier les traitements et peut-être
aussi en étant mieux informés on est
mieux adhérents au traitement je pense à
l'hormonothérapie dont vous parliez un
traitement on va dire complémentaires
voilà qui se prend par la bouche
pendant au moins cinq ans il est
patiente informés sont plus adhérente ça
c'est sûr et si on n'est plus adhérent
pro mieux son traitement et donc oui on
a une bonne survie restons justement
quelques instants sur cette question des
traitements parce que j'ai l'impression
que l'une des grandes difficultés du
traitement contre le cancer du sein
c'est la perte des cheveux et on voit et
on parle du rapport à l'image on parle
du rapport au corps et et on entend même
perte d'identité parce que ces jeunes
femmes et les autres d'ailleurs perdent
leurs cheveux ou est-ce qu'on en est est
ce que est ce que ce sera toujours ça
est-ce qu'on a d'autres traitements en
cours qui un jour enlèveront cet énorme
inconvénient c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas
beaucoup avancé on ne s'est pas beaucoup
améliorée pour la perte des cheveux
alors un petit peu quand même les
traitements majeur dans le cancer du
sein induisent une perte des cheveux ça
repousse après mais c'est sûr que c'est
un effet secondaire qui est physique et
qui est très visible
comment on fait pour essayer de diminuer
cette perte de cheveux on a on a des
propositions comme m qu'est-ce que voilà
réfrigérée sur la tête on va dire qui
alors convoité de rire c'est pas magique
c'est alors c'est agréable du tout voilà
c'est très froid déjà et on va dire que
ça recule le moment de la chute
finalement donc ça raccourci le moment
sans cheveux voilà ce qu'on propose donc
ça s'est essayé de prévenir la chute et
finalement après on a trop chaud ou pas
alors il ya un petit peu de recherches
là dessus mais je trouve que ça avance
pas vite et pas très vite ça sur la
chute des cheveux en fm c'est important
pour ces jeunes femmes l'ennemi nazi
c'est un des sujets majeurs du cancer du
sein de très bien sûr libres d'ailleurs
lorsqu'on m'a annoncé mon cancer du sein
je me souviens que la première chose qui
m'est venue à l'esprit c'était mais je
vais perdre mes cheveux mais si les mes
sourcils et c'est vrai que ça fait peur
parce qu'on
on sait que les gens vont nous voir tel
quel et qu'on voit là une cancer sera
affiché sur notre tête tous les jours et
ça c'est pas facile après voilà
heureusement il existe des perruques des
franges plein de manières de continuer
sans cesse de se sentir féminine mais
c'est vrai que cette perte d'identité
comme on disait dans le film c'est pas
facile à gérer tous les jours et c'est
qu'on se reconnaît plus et puis le temps
aussi prendre conscience que notre
apparence physique a changé c'est pas
évident je me souviens au tout début je
faisais des rêves où j'avais encore mes
cheveux longs pendant un bon moment et
puis après petit à petit je commence à
réaliser qu'en fait j'avais vraiment
perdu mes cheveux et c'est pas c'est pas
facile tout le temps après heureusement
ça repousse mais natacha et c'est
vraiment un sujet majeur c'est tout à
fait le problème du cancer du sein et
sur toutes ces traitements c'est que ça
ça c'est s'attaque à la féminité quand
même entre le saint les cheveux ludmila
en parler les poils les poils pubiens
aussi donc il ya effectivement une
impression d'étrangeté et comment se
reconnaître et je pense que ans un âge
aussi jeune c'est aussi compliqué parce
qu'on est encore dans la structuration
de sa féminité est donc là c'est je
pense que c'est vraiment une attaque
majeure mais c'est vrai que la page la
perte des cheveux est une atteint les
puissants visible c'est visible
dans la rue on sait que vous êtes mal
alors oui ou non parce que ça dépend il
ya de très belles perruque aujourd'hui
mines soi même ça nous laisse à leur
appel ça nous le rappellent tous les
jours aux fesses devant son miroir quand
on est démaquiller qu'on m'a plu de
perruques et c'est ça a vraiment je ne
sais pas comment le dire autrement
qu'une impression d'étrangeté il ya
vraiment ça c'est elle se reconnaît plus
cette année c'est plus vraiment nous
c'est nous mais plus tout à fait
alors je vois cette image il ya une
autre perte d'identité c'est quand on
perd son sein ou ses seins parce que
c'est une des identités aussi de la
femme etc je crois parce que les cheveux
repoussent le ça ne repousse pas donc
soit on passe par une reconstruction
soit j'entendais l'une des jeunes femmes
dire que pour l'instant elle s'assume en
amazone parce qu'elle voulait pas
retourner refaire une anesthésie mais là
aussi on a quelque chose qui définit la
féminité et compère et donc il faut
retrouver un repère accepté de
s'accepter enfin ce accepté justement
dans un corps qui n'est plus tout à fait
le corps de femme que l'on pouvait avoir
avant donc je pense que les cheveux
c'est dur et transitoire le saint c'est
plus définitif est plus douloureux et
une perte de chance de devenir maman
aussi on en est où dr
c'est une grande question parce que
justement chez la femme jeune la
question la maternité elle est
importante une grossesse après cancer du
sein au niveau écologique c'est pas
contre-indiqué c'est vrai on aurait pu
avoir cette fausse idée que la grossesse
est plein d'hormones non une grossesse
la grossesse n'augmente pas le risque de
récidive de cancer du sein donc c'est
possible a par contre c'est vrai qu'on
demande à nos jeunes patientes
d'attendre on leur demande d'attendre au
moins deux trois ans après la fin des
traitements pourquoi parce qu'il ya une
sorte de cap à passer et puis aussi chez
la majorité de nos jeunes femmes elles
ont un traitement d'hormonothérapie donc
ces comprimés qui sont pris par la
bouche et qui vont aider à la guérison
c'est exactement ce que vous disiez et
c'est important qu'elles prennent aussi
ce traitement pendant au moins de 3 ans
sachant que le traitement est plus long
mais au moins de 3 ans puis après
éventuellement une pause donc la
grossesse après cancer du sein c'est
possible la fertilité
et probablement oui moindre après cancer
du sein mais pour deux raisons parce que
justement comme on demande à nos
patientes d'attendre le temps passe et
vous savez que le temps n'est pas le bon
ami de la fertilité des femmes la
fertilité diminue spontanément avec le
temps dont des gens leur demandent du
temps et puis oui il ya certains
traitements qui vont avoir une toxicité
sur la fertilité ces traitements là
c'est la chimiothérapie c'est pour ça
qu'on parle de congélation d'ovocytes
exactement si les font fréquemment alors
cessé dépasse donc les jeunes patientes
il faut tout les informer justement sur
voilà les possibilités de grossesse est
de préserver la fertilité avant cancer
du sein dont elles sont toutes informés
certaines sont vus après en consultation
dans koh fertilité ou là on leur propose
des de la préservation comme on dit
invasive vous envoie vous en avez donné
une c2 la congélation ovocytaire ça
c'est la patiente qui décident de ce
qu'elle souhaite faire sachant que après
cancer du sein il ya quand même un
certain nombre de grossesses dont la
majorité sont des gros c'est spontané
heureusement voilà c'est la patiente qui
décide aussi si elle veut faire une
technique de préservation invasives
comme une congélation ovocytaire me l'a
dit est ce que c'est aussi une épreuve
pour le couple je pense que c'est pas
évident pour le couple à gérer parce que
forcément c'est un changement dans nos
vies il ya beaucoup de choses qu'on doit
revoir qu'on doit repenser différemment
on doit s'adapter à la situation c'est
des traitements qui sont longs et oui je
pense que c'est psychologiquement c'est
pas c'est pas évident et en même temps
c'est mieux d'être à deux noms natacha
espié on voit cette jeune femme qui dit
dans le documentaire
c'est pas facile j'aurais bien aimé
quelqu'un qui m'attendent la sésamie
après aux côtés voilà alors c'est
difficile de vous répondre comme ça je
pense que je vais vous dire ça dépend de
l'accompagnant mais c'est vrai que le
mia raison c'est quelque chose qui
forcément bouleverse le couple parce que
tous les équilibres sont remis en
question et ça dépend aussi beaucoup des
bagages psychique du couple qu'est ce
qu'ils étaient avant qu est-ce que ce
couple était avant et c'est ça aussi qui
va pouvoir déterminer ce qui va se
passer après c'est vrai que ça on voit
des couples qui sortent renforcées et
d'autres qui malheureusement se séparent
mais je vais racheter quelque chose par
rapport à ça
comment s'est souvent l'homme souvent
quitte une femme malade les pourcentages
sont assez épouvantable là dessus et
parfois je pense que l'homme peut aussi
avoir peur je me souviens de guillaume
le compagnon de maeva on avait discuté
un petit peu lors d'une soirée il
m'avait dit qu'il avait peur que maeva
et envie d'un changement dans sa vie
après et il avait peur d'être le
changement d'être la personne club voilà
être expulsé sa vie et je pense que
c'est pas évident pour eux aussi parce
que il voit là c'est un changement et
nous voit évoluer ils nous voient aussi
parce qu'à une certaine forme de prise
de conscience quand on est touché par
une maladie grave comme ça on se rend
compte à quel point la vie est belle vie
est importante on a en plus envie de
foncer peut-être de réaliser des choses
et claviers de rage elle aussi est que
la vie est fragile complètement et donc
peut-être que le compagnon ou la
personne qui avec qui partagent notre
vie peut avoir peur de tous ces
changements là aussi et
alors il quelque chose que vous avez
soulevé au tout début de l'émission on
va y venir un peu plus de manière plus
approfondie maintenant dominique vais
rien et c'est assez choquant et ça
apparaît effectivement assez bien dans
le film qui concerne d'ailleurs toutes
les personnes qui ont eu un concert mais
peut-être encore plus douloureusement
les femmes touchées à moins de 30 35 ans
40 ans ce sont les difficultés à obtenir
des prêts bancaires regardez
on était mariée on avait deux enfants là
on voulait acheter une maison c'était la
suite logique des choses
la veille de mon diagnostic on a reçu
une proposition de prix super
intéressante et le lendemain je dis donc
c'est que j'avais un cancer
donc ce sont il y avait rien signé donc
à voir le prés c'était juste plus
possible
mais c'est difficile en fait parce que
il ya la maladie
ya la peur
et les projets qui s'arrête
là vous parliez double peine mais là
c'est carrément la triba triple peine
parce que en plus alors qu'on se croient
guéris enfin les confins qu'on va vers
vraiment du mieux l'assureur vous
rappelle que vous avez un risque de
mortalité qui est supérieur à son ces
chiffres à lui et donc il peut pas vous
continuez vous faire confiance et vous
permettre de continuer votre vie c'est
c'est assez terrible donc c'est bien
c'est vraiment effectivement une mais là
j'ai envie de m'adresser à la scéne être
alors la lettre crise fr qu'est-ce que
d'un point de vue législatif on peut
changer ou telle à l'afp on invente tous
les jours des fonds pour pouvoir assurer
des jeunes qui veulent louer etc je
crois que là il faut effectivement
mettre en place quelque chose pour
pouvoir suivre c'est ces personnes le
temps
le temps de la guérison définitive ou là
l'assurance peut reprendre son cours
mais ou alors négocier quelque chose
avec des assurances mais il est évident
que on peut pas nous dire qu'on arrête
notre vie parce que un jour on a eu un
cancer à 30 ans et donc ça y est à 35
ans c'est fini on n'a plus le droit de
continuer donc évidemment il faut qu'on
soit là accompagnés afin que les jeunes
femmes en l'occurrence soit accompagné l
exemple des prêts bancaires mais gens me
dire c'est presque sociétal c'est
comment serait intègre au travail comme
en serait un dans la société quand on a
eu un cancer
on va complètement d'accord avec vous
c'est à dire effectivement les banques
et les prêts c'est un très gros problème
mais on est aussi à cet âge là en pleine
construction professionnel et c'est un
coup d'arrêt à tout qu'est ce qu'on dit
à son employeur si on vient de négocier
un contrat comment est-ce qu'on serait
un teg bon je rappelle quand même que
l'après cancer du sein c'est une période
compliquée on est fatigué il ya des
effets secondaires donc il faudrait
vraiment que ce soit aménagé ce qu'on
peut trouver un pour des femmes peut
être un peu plus âgé il ya des mi temps
thérapeutique
quid des jeunes filles femmes c'est
c'est toute la question et je pense
qu'il faudrait communiquer vraiment
auprès des employeurs et auprès de la
société parce qu'au fond c'est fini ton
cancer est fini tout va aller très bien
or on sait qu'on est pas du tout là
dedans et il va falloir du temps pour
récupérer du temps pour comprendre ce
qui s'est passé et pouvoir se reprojeter
dans le futur après du temps pour
récupérer et mais sans continuer à être
malade souvient qu'il avait
effectivement trouvé un accompagnement
qui fasse on reprend la vie et que c'est
normal de leur plan de la vie et qui
effectivement je pense que c'est très
compliqué quand on a vaincu la mort
quelque part de se redire qu on va
reprendre la vie d'albert façon et je
comprends ce changement qui peut se
produire
et donc là il faut aussi être accompagné
à reprendre une vie et à se dire que ben
voilà oui c'était une parenthèse
intense que les autres ne peuvent pas
comprendre au tour mais que pour autant
il faut se réintégrer dans cette société
l'unmis l'asie vous êtes dans la presse
vous comment ça se passe ce que c'est
facile de vous réintégrer socialement
dans le monde du travail ou est ce que
vous sentez des freins est ce que vous
devez cacher votre passé votre maladie
ou pas alors là encore une fois de plus
je pense que ça dépend vraiment de
chaque personne je sais que pour moi
c'était
en fait lorsque j'ai appris pour mon
cancer du sein je venais de terminer mes
études de journalisme et j'avais cette
inquiétude de ce que je vais réussir à
trouver du travail et comme j'ai fait
mes études à l'étranger en australie
lorsque je suis arrivé en france je me
suis dit je connais personne dans ce
milieu est ce que ça va être évident
pour moi de trouver du travail est là
d'autant plus après voilà un an de
traitement avoir eu un cancer comment ça
va se passer et j'ai eu la chance entre
guillemets de trouver assez rapidement
et je leur en ai parlé voilà ouvertement
lors des ans j'ai eu un cancer du sein
voilà pourquoi est ce qui est un gros
trou d'un an dans mon cv j'ai fait des
petites vidéos que j'ai post que j'ai
publié sur les réseaux sociaux vous
pouvez les voir si vous voulez et et
pour moi en fait ça a été vraiment un
moyen de retrouver une vie normale et de
re d'être replongée donc c'était un gars
vous avez retourner la situation c'est
devenu une force en fait oui c'est ça
complètement je m'en suis un peu servi
entre guillemets en me disant de toute
façon il est là j'ai pas le choix autant
d'utiliser essayer de voir ce que c'est
bien passé pour vous mais ce que vous
savez pour les autres si ça se passe
bien alors je pense que c'est pas
évident tout le temps mais il va
d'ailleurs l'expriment aussi dans le
film parce que ça chamboule beaucoup de
choses et notamment pour maeva elle
travaille dans le domaine de la santé et
je pense qu'une reprise du travail
parfois ça peut amener à beaucoup de
questionnements c'est déjà ce que je
suis illégitime et ce que je peux
vraiment me repartir au travail je suis
est-ce que d'être confronté des
personnes qui ont aussi vécu des
maladies graves ça va pas me renvoyer
des choses et tout ce questionnement là
et puis comme on a été un peu dans un
cocon pendant un an en traitement on est
bichonné il faut faire attention notre
vie est fragile
voilà on est vraiment pris voilà tout
prend soin de nous et puis se retrouver
dans mille du travail ça peut être un
peu violent parce que les gens savent
pas forcément vous avez un cancer et
vous traitent comme tout le monde donc
ça peut faire ya là bien bien
ça peut être difficile fatigué je ne
sais pas moi vraiment ça m'a permis de
rebondir et puis de voilà de continuer
rester active en disant c'est bon je
suis comme tout le monde ma vie reprend
et ça m'a fait du bien mais j'imagine
que c'est pas facile pour tout le monde
lorsqu'on si on est fatigué après
là on a parlé justement de l'après
cancer serait qu'on a quand même aussi
des données heureusement on a une très
belle étude qui s'appelle vic ans et vit
après cancer qui a été
qui a été menée grâce à l'institut du
cancer et donc on a justement ces
données grâce en ils ont appelé les
patientes et ont ils leur ont posé des
questions donc on a des zones est quand
même très précises donc on a des données
sur le couple on a quand même des
données rassurantes sur le couple dans
le cancer du sein des femmes voilà où
comme il ya majorité des couples ils
restent stables donc voilà il ya enfin
du parti des choses positives que je
tiens à souligner après il ya toujours
et puis oui il ya plus d'un tiers des
patientes qui sont fatigués après le
cancer il ya plus de 50 % des patientes
qui ont une baisse de la sexualité dont
on parle aussi passée baisse de la
libido sécheresse vaginale il ya aussi
un tiers des patientes qui présente on
va dire des comme on dit nous le quai no
brain des troubles cognitifs des trous
de la concentration et femmes qui
faisaient avant dix choses en même temps
qu'ils ne peuvent plus qu'en faire que
deux ça c'est très
bas et donc on a grâce à justement cette
étude on a maintenant une idée des
effets un petit peu de concerts et à
nous justement de mettre en place tout
ce qu'on peut aider en soins de support
et je vous rejoins aussi sur le travail
on a aussi des chiffres
à peu près deux ans après le diagnostic
de cancer du sein il ya encore 20 % des
femmes qui sont en arrêt de travail ces
femmes là c'est souvent des femmes qui
sont encore en arrêt travail parce qu'il
ya eu un traitement long parce qu'il ya
aussi des séquelles physiques
importantes de la douleur de la fatigue
à nous de de trouver des solutions je
suis d'accord il ya des entreprises
aussi qu'ils sont aussi qui aident à
trouver des solutions des associations
et je pense qu'il ya aussi beaucoup de
solutions qui viendront de vous parce
que c'est aussi à vous de nous dire
aussi qu'elle est la bonne manière de
vous aider pour certains de ses effets
ou même de ce retour au travail un petit
mot pour conclure peut-être lui mais là
pour conclure cette discussion vous êtes
optimiste sur la suite vous pensez que
les lignes vont bouger pour aider ces
jeunes femmes notamment j'espère oui
j'espère avant tout con on va réussir à
parler de la maladie sans tabou qu'on
puisse entendre s'exprimer à ce sujet
librement que ce soit au travail ou
ailleurs et qu'on soient considérés
comme des personnes normales puisque
c'est ce qu'on est aux enfants quel sera
le message de faire merci merci
infiniment à toutes les quatre des six
mais cette émission je vous rappelle
qu'en ce moment serait se déroule donc
l'opération octobre rose consacré à la
lutte contre le cancer du sein la
campagne est intitulée la marche des
saints le slogan cette année de
l'association ruban rose et prenez
rendez vous avec vos seins tous les ans
aller chez un médecin n'hésitez pas
aussi à faire un don si vous pouvez bien
sûr merci en tout cas à toutes les
quatre c'est la fin de cette émission à
très vite sur public sénat
[Musique]